le climat se réchauffe la planète
s'inquiètent eux ils sont plutôt
contents tous ces touristes visitent le
groenland
il y a huit ans encore cette beit est
inaccessible une bonne partie de l'année
complètement gelé le réchauffement des
températures a tout changé les
professionnels du tourisme se frottent
les mains
en bretagne nous avons commencé à
promener les touristes ici dès le mois
de février
c'est très très tôt avant à la même
période le bateau restait bloquée
algérie le groenland et ses petits ports
de pêche typique une nouvelle
destination à la mode pour les vacances
certes mais c'est à durée limitée
les guides sont très fiers de leurs
glaciers vieux de 350 mille ans ouais
mais voilà il aura totalement disparu
dans 15 ans et puis les promenades
romantiques en traîneau pourrait se
faire de plus en plus rares et de plus
en plus inconfortable
les chiens sont réduits à slalomer entre
les rochers et les flaques de boue
le meilleur moyen d'avancer ce sera
bientôt la course à pied